okay seems like people have stopped
entering so this is the gift parable
this is a 90 minute talk if you're
expecting to go out and get some beer in
45 minutes you will be sorely
disappointed I'm sorry
my name is yuan Harlem I'm a software
developer at Cisco Systems since 2011
I'm working on collaboration products
more specifically a video conferencing
before I worked at Opera Software for
seven years and I've also meddled with
git and distributed version control
since 2006 ish at opera I started the
migration from CVS to get and at Cisco I
was also involved in the migration from
subversion to get and I've also
occasionally contributed some code to
get to gate itself can everybody hear me
or should I put on the extra mic for the
speakers or is okay I'm gonna assume
everything is good if I'm going too fast
at any point feel free to stop me or if
something doesn't make sense to you this
is a starting point if we get questions
and we end up somewhere else that's fine
too
also I've been told by the organizers to
make a public announcement basically if
there's a fire here git commit get push
and get out so the following story that
you're about to hear its shamelessly
stole from Tom Preston burner who was
one of the guys that started github he
made a blog post in 2009 so this is
quite a old story and I'm stealing his
story basically because I'm lazy but
also it's the best introduction that I
found to get so far also a fair warning
I made these sleigh slides fairly late
at night and I found that we build or
support animated slide transitions yeah
you'll see those
so gate is a simple and powerful system
and often people try to teach gate by
showing all the different good commands
and then once they're sort of satisfied
that I've covered most use cases they
basically ill Tarara that's get I don't
do jazz hands i I don't believe this is
the best approach to teach gate and it
lets you use get to perform some simple
tasks but the git command still feel
like sort of magic incantations doing
anything out of your ordinary workflow
will feel terrifying because you only
know those commands and until you
understand some basic concepts about yet
you'll feel like a stranger in foreign
land
so instead I'll tell your story actually
I'm going to tell you a parable I will
take you on a journey through the
creation of a system that's very similar
to get from the ground up and the
concepts are very simple behind the
system but I feel that understanding
because concepts is the most valuable
thing you can do to understand and fully
appreciate get and and learn to use it
well as I said the concepts are very
simple but they allow for an amazing
functionality like Lego blocks when you
can build whatever you want and
hopefully after hearing this parable you
should have everything you need to know
to easily master the various good
commands and to become a gift power user
so imagine that you have a simple
computer and there's nothing on that
computer except for a text editor and a
few file system commands and you've
decided to write a large software
program on this system but you're
responsible self-refer so you must keep
track of the versions of your code so
that you can retrieve code that you've
previously changed or deleted and what
follows is a story on how you might
design this version control system and
the reasoning behind those design
choices but first before we started
project Alfred Alfred is a friend of you
he works as a photographer and he takes
awkward family photos for living
basically Alfred tells you a story about
hazel and she brings her daughter in
every year on the set at the same time
and she likes to remember what her
daughter was like at each different
stage and as if these snapshots let her
move back and forth in time to those
save memories you suddenly see the ideal
solution to your version control dilemma
so what you actually want are snapshots
you want snaps or its natural sort of
like save points in a video game and
basically what if you could take these
snapshots of your codebase at any time
and then redirect those nut shots later
if you want to basically restart from
somewhere else so you go back to your
computer and you start working you
basically started with a directory
called working that's where you
basically keep your codebase and you try
to write one feature at a time and when
you can complete a self-contained
portion of a feature you basically copy
your entire working directory so that
you basically have that version of the
code in a separate directory but you're
going to make a lot of these copies so
you're basically renaming it to snapshot
zero so that's your first night right
now the key here is you will never again
change anything inside snapshot zero
it's just a snapshot of what the code
looked like at that point in time so you
do some more work and you create a new
snapshot and you keep going now to
remember what kind of changes happened
in each snapshot you basically add a
special file called message where you
basically note down the date when you
made that snapshot and some comment
about what you did there and you put
that message file within the snapshot
and you do that for all the different
snapshots so now if you want to find a
specific change you can search through
this message files to basically find the
note you made when you introduced that
change and when you did it so after some
time you basically get to some something
that you're ready to release and you
basically decide to release this
snapshot night
9 as your version 1.0 so you package it
up and release it and your users love it
and you push forward determined to make
the next version even an even greater
success so you keep coding keep adding
more features but then bug report starts
coming in people are not so happy with
your software after all these bug
reports are made against your version
1.0 or your snapshot 99 so what you do
is in order to fix those bugs you copy
the code inside snapshots 99 into your
working directory and now you can fix
those bugs but then a problem becomes
apparent so your version control system
up till this point deals very well with
linear development but for the first
time you need to create a new snapshot
that is not a direct descendant of the
previous nutshot so your stuff 110 here
with the bug fixes for version 1.0 it
doesn't directly descend from 109 it
descends from 99 so how do you deal with
that use your sort of breaking the
linear flow and clearly you need
something more powerful than a linear
system but it's time to have a break and
you take a walk outside outside you walk
past an oak tree and you look more
closely at your oak tree and the
structure of the tree and the branches
and you start looking at the branch tip
and how you can follow it back to the
branch roots and to the root of the tree
so the tree is a very complex structure
but the rules for finding your way back
to the root of the tree are so simple
and they're perfect for keeping track of
multiple lines of development so you
have another epiphany by looking at your
code history as a tree you can basically
solve this problem of ancestry which
snapshot did I come from
so you need each snapshot to point to
the previous snapshot all the way back
to the root so the first natural you
made don't have a parent but all the
other ones basically point back to the
previous snapshot so how do you store
this point here so we need snapshot we
want to point back to snap to 0 well you
can add a note in this message file
saying that our this snapshot the parent
of this nut shot is not
zero so you just add it into the message
file and you've solved your problem now
this pointer enables you to accurately
trace the history all the way back to
the root and now your code history has
basically become a tree instead of just
the line so at this point though after
doing this development and the bug fix
on on version 1.0 you don't really have
one latest snapshot anymore you have two
latest snapshot you have the one where
you did your most recent development but
you also have this one where you made
the bug fixes to version one and this
idea of organizing things as a tree
might lead you to want to make more
lines of development you might want to
say may make some bug fix based on some
earlier version or you must keep
developing your mainline development or
you might find other bug fixes to make
on your version one so you'll have to
keep track of all these different
branches how do you yeah how do you not
lose track of your branches so when you
create a branch like this you typically
associate some meaning to it so in this
case when you sort of look at this
latest Nitra you sort of think of that
okay this is my master branch this is
where my main development happens this
is where I add new features and this is
sort of your version one and maintenance
branch so um basically you add another
text file this text file lives outside
your working tree you just call it
branches and here you basically make a
point saying that ah I have a master
branch right now it's pointing to
snapshot 109 so 109 is the latest nut
shot on my master branch and my 110
snapshot is my latest nut fell on what
we call the version 1.0 maintenance
branch and if you want to switch to a
given branch you basically look up this
file you figure out which is a snapshot
for this branch and then you copy that
great into your working directory and
you can start working on it so because
you're only storing the latest snapshot
on each branch when you create a new
snapshot you need to make another step
so if the or when the new snapshot is
created as part of a branch you need to
update the branch pointer from this file
so here after 1:10 if I make another
change on that branch 111 I create the
111 snapshot inside there it's a message
file pointing back to 110 that's this
arrow but also in my branch's file I
need to update my 1.0 mayn't pointer
saying that oh this is no longer 110
it's now 111 that's a small price to pay
for being able to keep track of
everything and after using branches for
a while you notice that you want to make
a different kind of reference to
snapshots so you want to keep track of
some snapshots but not with the aim of
changing them later but with the aim
we're just remembering that art this is
one importance natural so say let's see
here oh yeah there's a error in the
slicer but basically you want to
remember snapshot 99 that was the
version 1.0 so you want to call that 1.0
you want to put a name to it and with
the same thing when you when you're bug
fixed version 1.0 and you probably
release this as 101 or something like
that you want to remember that name as
well to take these names and the
snapshots they link to and you store
that in a separate file and you call
that file tags that's basically just
tags pointing to snapshots that you want
to give a special name to now working on
your own gets pretty lonely wouldn't it
be nice if you could invite a friend to
work on your product with you you're in
luck your friend Zoe has a computer set
up just like you and she wants to help
with the project so you basically start
by you tell her all about your great
version control system and use basically
send her a copy of all your snapshots
and your branches and your tags so she
can enjoy the same benefits of the whole
code history
and then obviously she has her own
working directory where she does her
work it's great to have Zoey on the team
but she has a habit of taking long trips
to faraway places without internet
access and as soon as she has the source
code she catches to fly to Pedigo Nia
and you don't hear from her for a week
in the meantime you both do a lot of
coding so when she finally gets back you
discover a critical flaw in your version
control system because you've both been
using the same numbering system you each
have directories named snapshot 114 and
115 but the code inside them is
different and to make matters worse you
don't even know who wrote the changes in
each snapshot like for now you know that
she wrote those changes but if you try
to combine them you want to keep track
of who actually made these changes so
together you devise a plan for dealing
with these two problems so now in this
message file where you're sort of
storing metadata on your snapshots you
had some more information you add first
of all you add a line noting who was the
author so here I'm the author and over
here is always the author and then you
shouldn't and you basically discover
that and we should name our snapshot
with simple numbers we need something a
bit more clever so first of all this
everybody here know what sha-1 or
cryptographic hashes anybody feel like
they need an introduction of that okay
I'll assume sha-1 is no good so um let's
just take that message file and put it
through sha-1 and you will get a unique
identifier for this method data and now
let's just rename the snapshot folder
with that ID instead so now you won't
have the problem that her changes are in
the folder that has the same name as
your changes if if these files are
different and they will be because at
least the author is different and the
date is probably different as well then
basically those two folders will also
have different names
so they will never conflict so you both
update your code histories renaming all
your folders based on the sha-1 of the
message file well all down the code is
trace so now you have these folders and
now they have different names because
the messages are different with this
updated naming scheme you can now fetch
all your snapshots from from Zoey's
computer and place them next to your
existing snapshots and for all the code
history that's shared those you already
have those so you only need to copy the
stuff that's always actually made on top
so you get those two folders and they're
basically sitting next to your snapshots
as well so now suddenly in your tree you
have code or snapshots that have been
authored by you and also by the way so
this point is really important so I'll
repeat it a snapshot is identified by
the sha-1 of the message file and that
uniquely identifies it and its parents
these snapshots can be created and moved
around between computers without losing
their identity or where they belong in
the history of our project the message
file always says that ah my parent it's
not released this one and my parents
natural is this one and you can always
trace the snapshots back down to the to
the start of the history finally you can
share these snapshots as you see fit
if you have some experimental snapshots
that you want to keep to yourself
you just don't make them available to
Zoe so you can have your own snapshot
somewhere else if you're really
secretive about something there's always
travel habits
Kosar to spend countless hours on
airplanes and boats and most of these
places the places that she visit don't
have readily available internet access
but at the end of the day she spends
more time offline than online it's no
surprise then that so it really raves
about your version control system
because all of the day-to-day operations
that she does she can do those locally
she don't need internet access
everything the whole code history is
available on her
the only time she needs a network
connection is basically when you share
changes so let's simplify drawings a
little we don't need to draw this
working directory we can just assume
it's always there the branches syntax
file the same thing instead we'll add
these labels that sort of point to where
in the code history the branches and
tags are currently I the green ones are
for branches so we have this version 1.0
maintenance branch here we have the
master branch and I added a branch
called mouth for the new work that Zoey
did and here are the tags so we have the
version 1.0 tag that we released and
then we have the bug fixed at one point
or one version finally let's draw the
snapshots as simple dots these are like
we can still think of them as folders
with with parent pointers back but let's
just draw them as simple dots the the
arrows in the previous diagram they're
always pointing down so back into
history so we can just draw them as
simple lines instead and we have this
simple graphs so here's the root of the
project and basically time and
development flows upwards
now before Zoey left on a trip you offer
to do some to start working off of the
branch that we called moss to implement
a function that say generates prime
numbers or something and she's done so
she's made three new snapshots on that
branch but in the meantime you were also
developing on the moth branch so you
were writing say a different function to
generate magic numbers or something
so you made these two snapshots now that
Zoey has returned you're faced with the
task of merging her work and your work
but how do you do that so in the working
directory you can copy the changes made
on both branches and you can reconcile
the differences so she added a function
okay you'll keep that function that she
added you added a function make sure
that that's still there and you
basically create a new snapshot in your
working directory containing the merged
result of those changes but now you need
to create a snapshot from that working
directory there's something special
about this not thought because it
derives not only from your previous
state but it also dries from her
previous state so the first parent of
this new snapshot is your work and you
can add a second parent to the same
snapshot which is her work this is our
first snapshot that has more than one
parent once you've completed the merge
so we can just fetch all the snapshots
that she didn't already have so
basically the your two blue ones and the
merge onto her computer and your
histories much exactly and you can keep
keep working you basically synchronize
your histories now like many software
offers you have a compulsion to keep
your code clean and we're well organized
and you also have to desire to keep your
code history well-groomed but last night
you came home after having a few too
many pints of Guinness you started
coding and you produced a handful of
snapshots this morning when you look at
that code
yeah it makes you cringe a little bit
well actually the end result of the code
is pretty good but you made some
mistakes on the way and you'd like to
sort of clean those up you don't want
that messy history sort of State stay
around so let's let's say the branch on
which you did your drunken development
is called drunk and you made three three
snapshots after you got home from the
bar if now as a small aside let's invent
some notation here to just talk about
different snapshots so if the name drunk
points to this latest snapshot let's
invent this name drunk carrot or hat
drunk hat to point to the parent of that
snapshot and then we can we can keep
going and basically say drunk hat hat is
the grandparent so that's basically just
a way of naming commits that aren't
directly at the tip of your history but
for the back now say that the end result
of this drunk branch basically what you
did along this branch when you look at
it now is okay you did two two different
things you you you change an existing
function food to do something else and
then you added a new file called bar
you'd really like these three lousy
snapshots to be to clean or snap
snapshots one that changes the existing
function foo and another snapshot that
just adds the new a new file bar so you
basically take the end result here from
from the drunk development you copy it
into your working directory and then you
remove that bar file so that you're only
left with the first change the first
change you want to record in a snapshot
and then you can create a new snapshot
and use drunk hat hat hat so basically
the start of your drunk branch as the
parent for the snapshot and this nut
slot compared to this now simply changes
that function foo and thus does the
change you want to reflect unless it's
not
and then you can copy this drunk once
again interworking and then just create
a snapshot directly now the change from
here to here we basically just be adding
that second file bar and you may can use
national based on light so here is your
sort of cleaned up history yeah and the
parent of that snapshot is obviously the
the previous national you you just made
and at this point the only thing left to
do is basically just move the drunk
parent a branch pointer over to point to
this snapshot instead these snapshots
here
well you don't care about them you you
you basically you can delete them from
the tree they're not referenced by any
branches so if you go looking at your
code history little later you probably
won't find them at all because they're
not referenced by any of these branches
you can delete them from from the
snapshots directory if you want to now
um let's talk a bit about what we'll
know is the staging area now as much as
you try to keep your new modifications
related to a single feature or a single
logical change you sometimes get
sidetracked and you start hacking on
something completely different and only
half way into that you'd suddenly
realize that ah my working directory now
sort of has a combination of two
different things
I really should separate these two as
two discreet snapshots so to help you
with this annoying situation let's
invent the concept of a staging
directory so next your working directory
you create a staging and this is sort of
where you'll prepare the next snapshot
this is where you do all your
development this where you do your
builds it's where you do your debugging
everything but here this is reserved for
basically this is the stuff that will go
into the next snapshot and each time you
finish a snapshot you first basically
copy the code you want in that's not
foot into the staging directory and then
you make this as the and then you copy
that into your snapshots folder and make
it part of the other history and update
the branch pointer and everything
so with these two different sets of
changes if you want to make a snapshot
or if these changes belong in that
snapshot you basically copy them over
into staging but if these other changes
don't belong in the snapshot you just
leave them in working you don't copy
them into staging and then when you make
the snapshot you'll get the you'll get
them into the snapshot these others are
just left in working not copied into
staging so separating this concept of
where you're working and where you're
creating is not flow it's it makes it
much easier to specify what is included
and what is not included into the next
national you don't have to worry too
much about making other accidental
changes your working directory because
it's what's in here in staging that
actually becomes part of your snapshot
you have to be a bit careful though
because say say you're changing a file
called readme
and you first make one change and okay I
want to make this part of the the next
natural so I'll copy those changes into
staging and then you keep making some of
the changes into read me now you need to
remember to copy those into staging as
well if you want those changes to be
part of the same it's natural so the
lesson is this basically every new edit
must be added to state the staging area
if it is to be part of the next nutshot
now with the working directory a staging
directory and loads of snapshots lying
around it starts to get confusing as to
where the specific code changes are and
what are the different differences from
one directory to another so you'll want
to like the the message file inside it's
not shot it only gives you a summary of
what what changed it doesn't really tell
you exactly what lines have changed so
you will want to look at so what are the
exact changes for example between
working in staging so basically what
what is the work that I haven't stage
for the next natural yet or what's the
difference between what I'm working on
right now and what's in one of these
snapshots what's the difference between
what I've staged and the law snapshot so
basically what will become the next nut
shot if I make one right now or you'll
have to you'll want to
the difference between say what's the
difference between a my master branch or
the latest natural here and the latest
acts of them on the mouth branch so
let's introduce a diff algorithm so a
different algorithm basically takes two
folders in this case and taking staging
and the working folder and it spits out
a result which is basically a text
listing the changes so we're doing
source code here so it's all text-based
it's very nice and easy to look at
changes one thing you'll notice when you
work with git is that you'll you'll
sooner or later get used to reading this
it's a nice format for seeing seeing
what has changed basically so here we're
basically saying that okay moving from
staging into working you'll have to
remove this line and you'll have to add
that line so those are the changes
between staging and working and as you
develop and you copy things from working
into staging you'll use this to see okay
what's left - what changes remain in
working that are not in staging and do I
want to copy those as well into staging
it's also important to see how the
staging area is different from the last
night Roy so you can use the same diff
algorithm you just select different
directories to compare and you get a
different result of obviously there are
many other dips you might want to see
you might want to see the changes
introduced by specific snapshots and you
they basically do that by deferring
that's not shot against its immediate
parent or you'll want to see the changes
between branches so basically how far
has the math branch diverged off of my
master branch well you can compare those
two snapshots and the diff output will
tell you now remembers away after a few
more trips around the world she starts
to complain that her her hard drive is
filling up with hundreds of nearly
identical copies of a software remember
that each of these snapshots is a full
copy of your working directory at that
point so you have all these copies of
your entire project from the entire
history or everything you two have been
feeling that all this file duplication
is wasteful and after a bit of thinking
you come up with something very clever
you remember the sha-1 algorithm it
produces a short string well relatively
short string that is unique for a given
file contents now starting with the very
first snapshot in the project history
you start a big conversion process first
you create a new directory called
objects very basically gonna store all
the stuff that you're now consolidating
and by the way this is where the slide
animation goes crazy so you go into the
first snapshots directory you unpack
that directory or we basically just just
go into the directory structure and you
look at everything that's there you
create a temporary file somewhere and
for each file in the most deeply nested
directory so basically the sort of leaf
nodes of your file structure so in here
you perform the following three steps
step one you take the file you pull it
through sha-1 and you get this checksum
step two you add an entry in the
temporary file the entry is base so this
is just a regular text file there are
three columns we use the word blob
some say it's a abbreviation for binary
large object or something but basically
we'll so we'll just call it a blob and
we take the checksum that we just
calculated we put that in there and we
take the name of the file for for which
that checksum is the correct one and we
put that in the third column that's step
two and the step three is basically we
take this file we rename it using its
checksum and we put it into the objects
directory
we repeat this process for the other two
files so we take file too we calculate
the sha-1 we take that sha-1 we put it
into the temporary file with the
filename and then we move the file into
the objects directory renaming it with
its show on some same thing for the last
file here calculate the sha-1 put it
into the temporary file move the file
into the object directory ya objects
directory contains three files file one
two and three but renamed using the
sha-1 it shows ohms and then this
temporary file you take that template
file which has three lines one for each
file you put it through the sha-1 and
you get the shower sha-1 some for the
temporary file and then you put the
temporary file also into the abreast
directory named by its shell want some
so note that the contents of this
temporary file it exactly mirrors the
directory listing of this directory here
we'll use this fact in the next phase so
now we move up f1 directory and we start
over so for this directory here sub sub
there one we want to create an entry it
doesn't make sense to take the directory
itself and pull through sha-1 but we
take we use this template file the
directory listing we made in the last
step and we use the sha-1 some of that
to identify sub sub there one and this
is a tree we call that a tree instead of
a blob because it represents a directory
and not a dragger file
at this level there's also regular file
we pull it through sha-1 we get insurers
awesome we recorded that in the
temporary file with the file name it's a
blob and then we move that file into the
objects as well and when we finish this
directory we do the same thing we take
the temporary file pull it through sha-1
we get the shot some for the temporary
file and we put it into objects and in
this fashion you can build a tree of
directory object files that contain the
shell ones and the names of the files
and directories or directory objects
that they contain so sort of recreate
the whole directory structure but with
these temporary files and their sha-1
sums and it's all stored inside objects
once this has been complex and files in
your snapshot you're left with one shot
um which is basically represents the
contents of the top directory in your
snapshot now you need to record this
sha-1 some somewhere but where well you
have this message file within the
snapshot so you can pull up this message
file and you can add a line saying that
ah the contents of this snapshot is
identified by this show some that points
to this tree which is inside objects and
now this changes the message file so
it's also changes the name of the
snatchers itself because that's
calculated from the sha-1 some of the
message file so the uniqueness of sha-1
of the message now also depends on the
entire contents of your snapshot all the
files and directories have gone into the
calculation of that line and that line
goes into the calculation of the name of
the snapshot
it's also convenient to create sort of
an object in your object directory from
the message file itself the same way you
do for blobs increase so we take the
conference here we pull it through sha-1
this the name the new name of the
snapshot and we store this message file
inside objects under that name and this
is known or will will MIT will call this
a commit object so now we have three
different kinds of objects inside our
objects directory we have commit
objects-- which are basically these text
files and then we have three objects
which represented the directories of our
directory structure and we have blob
objects which represents files within
those directories and since you're
maintaining this list of branches and
tags you can now use this sha wants them
to identify where a branch is pointing
so this is this is the identifier for a
whole snapshot and you can use that when
you record it into the branch's file or
into the text file with all this
information stored in the objects
rectory
you can now safely delete this natural
directory itself because everything is
inside objects if you want to
reconstitute the snapshot at a later
date you basically just follow the
shamans into objects and you're
basically sort of pull out the files
that are referenced from the trees and
blobs and we can recreate the whole
directory structure now for this single
snapshot down here this whole process
doesn't really give you much at all
you're still using the same disk space
they're just now all different files
inside objects but they're still the
same size all the files are still there
you haven't saved anything
you basically just converted one type of
file system into a different kind of
file system and you do a lot of work in
the process but once you start
transforming the second snapshot you
discover something many of the files and
directories in the second snapshot
haven't changed from the first snapshot
there is same files and when you pull
them through this sha-1 process they'll
get the same name
so you'll end up reusing a lot of the
objects from your first snapshot in your
second snapshot the only new objects you
need to add into objects are for the
files and directories that were changed
in the second snapshot so imagine two
sequential snapshots in which only a
single file in the tough directory
changed if there's enough shots
if the snapshot otherwise contains like
say ten different directories and 100
files your transformation process will
create first first you'll get ten ten
trees and one hundred blobs from the
first snapshot but for the second
snapshot you'll only get one additional
tree and one additional blob and the
real benefit comes when you do this
across the whole history because
basically what you get is the objects
that corresponds to changes in your
system and not full copies or every
snapshot by doing this you drastically
reduce the number of files that are
stored on the disk instead of storing
nearly 50 identical copies of a rarely
changed file you only need to keep one
copy eliminating this duplication
between snapshots reduces the total
storage size but you can go in and
further because we're doing dealing with
source code here is just text it
compresses really well so each of those
objects files inside the object array
you can just pull them through set lib
and save even more space so now you get
to the point where the objects directory
actually takes a surprisingly small
amount of space but still contains your
entire project history so this is
basically get this is the fundamental
core concepts of get what you have
created here this version control system
is actually reasonable approximation or
what gate does the main difference is
that gate gives you command-line tools
to handle a lot of higher-level
operations
git uses the term commit instead of
snapshot that should be
obvious by now it gives you a lot of
other tools for looking through the
history keeping your branch tips
up-to-date fetching changes from other
people
the default grid am I talked about it's
all built in to get and hundreds of
other common and not so common tasks and
finally to sort of get you started with
the gate I assume most of you might have
used to get already but this is sort of
this is the point where you start
introducing git commands first when you
start using it you should tell git who
you are basically configure your user
dot name and you use that email so that
when you create these snapshots the
author line that identifies who made
these commits it actually makes sense if
you want help on a git command get
command dash H gives you a fairly short
help on the command line get help with a
command gives you a much larger manual
page with all the options it can be
quite frightening at first to see the
amount of options that some git commands
have and the command line interface is
not always as nice as we'd like it to be
but I've found that the combination of
looking at the manual page and searching
through it for the words that you are
looking for helps why yeah and to
starting you get repository it's it's
really simple if if you've come from
like a centralized version control
background you're you used to like oh we
need to setup a version control server
somewhere and stuff like that no will
get you basically just to get in it and
it starts it creates a dot git directory
in your current directory and in there
is where it stores all your branches
your tags the snapshots everything I've
shown you
so to move changes from your working
directory into the staging directory
that's what good at a gift ad does so ad
is basically about adding changes to be
put into the next commit and then to
make a new snapshot from the staging
directory that's what get to commit does
and if you basically have a simple
change any basically just want to put it
into staging get out it's natural from
it in one command that's git commit - a
takes all your changes in your working
directory and just creates this natural
directly or a commit git log is what you
use to look at the history of your
project so it basically starts listing
your most recent snapshot at the top and
then the previous nap float all the way
back through history and it has tons of
options to limit what you're looking at
or yeah limit it only to snapshots that
change a certain part of the project or
something like I get K is a nice GUI
command that is pretty much get logged
but in a GUI so it gives it it draws
this nice graph that shows you the
snapshots just like this natural sway
we've seen and you can scroll up and
down you can search around and you can
look at the diffs and everything and get
status is really really useful it tells
you about it gives you a summary of the
the changes in your working directory
and also the changes in your staging
directory it lists some changes or
unstaged basically meaning that these
are changes in your working but they
haven't been replicated in the staging
they haven't been staged for commit yet
and all the changes have been staged but
it's a really really nice command for
just getting an overview of ok what's my
current state to see the differences
between the working directory and the
staging area you can just use git diff
without any any any arguments
so that the force to basically okay what
other stage what are the changes that I
haven't yet staged for commit and get if
- are staged will then say oh these are
the changes that I have stage four
commit so basically the diff between
what's in the staging directory and
what's in the latest is not right if you
want to see the diff from the latest not
fraud across staging into working so
basically what was the difference
between my loss commit and what's
currently in my working directory you
basically get diff against head so head
is the magic name that get uses for the
lost commit of the branch I'm currently
on and then you can use get if from one
snapshot turn all this natural you just
identify the two snapshots get branch
shows you a list of your branches you
can also use git branch to create new
branches and then you use git checker to
change to that branch and you can do
both in one operation with the dash be
option to check out get tagged dash L
lists your current tags and to create a
new tag you basically do get tagged and
then the name of the tag and that will
create a tag pointing to your most
recent commit the commit you've sort of
currently checked out if you want to tag
a different commit you can just name
that as a second parameter to start
talking to another git repo you use git
remote add to tell I get about where to
to contact that for a repo and then you
give it a shorthand name this name is
called a remote it's basically just a
reference to some other git repo it
might be on some of the machine it might
be on the same machine it might be over
SSH or it might be over HTTP all that is
sort of identified by the URL and then
you can use git fetch to just fetch
changes from that remote one important
point dye
it's worth noting is that when you run
git fetch it never changes anything in
your working directory or your staging
directory
it only fetches snapshots from that
other remote but it doesn't change
anything you're working on right now
basically in order to actually integrate
changes from someone else into your
changes you need to run a git merge so
that sets up the whole merge process
where you get conflict markers if there
are if if gate is not able to
automatically resolve the differences
and you basically call it by saying so
if I have a remote called in my case or
in the sampler I'd probably have remote
calls away which is the URL to her
machine I would say git fetch the way to
get her changes onto my machine and then
I'd call git merge Zoe slash master if
I'm merging our master branch to
actually integrate those changes with my
combine those changes with my own so
that I can get the conflicts and resolve
them if I need to and actually create
that merge commit a table and get full
is basically just this command followed
by that command if factions has changes
and does the merge there is a rebase
commander I'm not covering rebase today
basis slightly more advanced topic but
basically get pulled data tree base is
get fetch followed by git rebase instead
of get merge but it's important to note
that get pull is not really a
fundamental command in the it's a
composite command it does two things and
you can do the first half without
worrying about changing what you're
currently at so you can you can see what
someone else has done look at their
commits without having to start the
whole merge
as you continue to learn gear keep this
parable in mind it's get is really very
simple underneath it doesn't look simple
at all when you look at the manual pages
and all the options and all the commands
and what you can do and yeah but this
simple design of the core is basically
what makes it so flexible and so
powerful one thing to keep in mind as
well one last thing is remember that
it's almost impossible to lose work that
has been committed if you have committed
if there is a snapshot of it if you've
told yet about these changes yet will
work very hard to remember those changes
even when you delete a branch all that
you really delete is this label the
commits all the snapshots are still
there at some point if you later do a
garbage collect get will get might start
removing snapshots that are not
referenced by any branch but really just
deleting a branch doesn't kill any
snapshots all the snapshots will still
be in the objects directory you just
need to find the sha-1 if you're missing
something and in those cases get ref log
is really really useful get ref log is
basically just a text log that keeps
track of where your branches have been
pointing in time so say you end up
somehow losing your Moss branch or I
know that I have this code checked out
yesterday but I don't I lost track of it
somehow you can look up get red flag and
say the ref log for your head which is
basically where where where were your
checked out at any point in time you can
just go down the log and look at the
dates and figure out ah on this state I
was checked out there that's the sha-1
for the commit that was checked out on
and then you can maybe create a new
branch the points that I've that commit
and sort of restart from there ref log
is really really useful if you've messed
up and lost track of your branches or
something
here are some worried sources
get home page has a link to pro get pro
get a pretty good introductory book on
gear it shows you most of the workflow
some commands github is obviously the
biggest company sort of making a
business round gate it's where a lot of
code is shared these days and it's
certainly a whole ecosystem of its own a
lot of people confuse git and github
github is really totally separate from
get its there are core developers in get
that work for github but that's as close
as it gets there's nothing in get that
depends on github it's not like if get
up went bankrupt and get would stop
existing or something I added two
websites down here because they make it
easy to sort of start experimenting with
git learn give branching is basically a
JavaScript website that lets you do get
commands and it'll draw the graph of
that you're creating with those commands
right next to it so you can do a git
commit and you can see the snapshot pop
up and you can switch browsers you can
see basically what happens with this
graph that I showed you when you do
different commands get ready it's a nice
site it has a lot of sort of oh I want
to do this what's the right command yeah
it's a different way of sort of learning
learning various commands so ya know go
and become a git master yeah thanks and
questions yes that is impossible to
answer very shortly so subversion is the
centralized version control system you
have a server somewhere that sits on the
code and its history when you start
working on a subversion project you
check out some version of that code what
is now on your machine locally is that
version of the code
and actually a copy of that version as
well so that you can when you do a
subversion diff that is the local
operation but if you want to look at the
history of subversion you need to talk
to a server if you need to commit
something obviously you need to talk to
a server because all the commits live on
the server this is such a fundamental
difference that when you have a
subversion mental model and try to
retrofit it on to get commands things
become really surprising and confusing
really quickly because something that
like for example the whole concept of a
staging area there's something where you
prepare your next commit the subversion
and and lots of other version control
systems don't have that the whole idea
yeah like check out switching branches
it all needs to talk to the server
that's that's very different
I think I'm it's a long time since I
looked at subversion I think for example
in subversion so if we if we go back
here a few steps ok so ok look at this
graph here for example inside our
snapshots there's nothing in the
snapshot itself that says that all this
snapshot was part of the master branch
no no I can have my master branch
pointing pointing here and then I can
take my mouth branch and point that
there as well
and there is nothing inside the snapshot
that says that oh I belong to master not
math these these nuts are just as much
part of the master branch as they are of
the moth branch if the branch pointers
point to or include those commits so I
think there is one big difference
between getting any other version
control systems because the commit
itself will have some concept of I
belong to this branch you don't have
adding it the branches are just labels
that points somewhere into the to the
commit graph so yeah that sort of just
scratches the surface
but these differences of concepts make
for a lot of confusion if you run a git
command that sounds like a subversion
command and you expect it to behave like
a subversion command sometimes it will
work fine but sometimes it won't
yeah and also this concept of having the
commit as a graph structure where you
can actually do merges that merges like
this one that has two parents and point
into both lines of development that led
up to them that that comes back to the
same point in that this so at this point
when we merged Zoe's math branch into my
mouth branch if these commits had some
internal concept of which which branch I
belong to then this merge merge commit
would have service schizophrenic idea
okay which prompt do I really belong to
because they're so small punch and there
is my mouth branch so yeah these
conceptual differences make it really
really hard to become productive with
git if you hang on to a centralized
mental model and this is the whole point
of why I start talking about the mental
model before I start talking about any
git commands no yeah
the staging part that's sort of a design
choice that Linnaeus Torvalds made when
he created yet that he want to die you
could envision I get without a staging
area but once it's there some people
find it hard to sort of rafter around or
or learn how to use it properly but once
you get used to it it's a really
powerful concept I use it a lot for say
I have like say I'm doing five different
things in my working directory at the
same time but I only staged the few
things that I want in this commit and
it's a huge help in making sure
my commits are single-issue have a
narrow focus and have yeah it makes me
much easier to write good commit
messages well yeah okay so the question
is basically a commit in get is the
local operation a commit is not
reflected on the server what happens if
your computer crashes and you lose your
work or something and yes this is one of
the fundamental differences between get
and or really between distributed
version control systems and centralized
conversion control systems a commit in
get is local to your machine and nobody
else knows the way not the server not
anybody knows about our commit until you
either push it or they pull it from you
there's a question back there first yes
yeah yes yeah so the question is
basically when you create a commit and
you basically move these files into the
objects directory do you move the whole
file or do you just move the changes in
that file you move the whole file
because yes you would believe that if
you just move the diff you could save
even more space but then you would need
the diff and the previous version and
the all the previous versions of that
file in order to reconstruct it when you
want to check it out later it's much
faster to reconstruct the file when you
have the whole file there as one object
also I told you the first half of the
story the objects directory
it actually works like I told you here
when you start in your git repo but at
some point get figures out that are
having all these
objects lying around in one directory
it's not efficient file system usage so
it has a repack process where it starts
taking a lot of objects and packing them
into one pack file it's still the same
format in that it's still identified
with the same sha-1 sums and you pull it
out in the same way you just have some
tools to help you do it but when when
gate does that repacking it then starts
doing things like Delta compression
across objects to save even more space
so yes get just what you want but it
doesn't do it at the top level of the
objects directory it happens as an
implementation detail in further down
into the tools Patricia had a question
first
[Music]
yeah so so Patricia makes the point that
you don't have to push to the master
branch on the server you can push your
own branch a bull or an atom to that
answer is basically this is also part of
what makes or what having the right
mental model is is is important because
the way in which get functions so
differently from say subversion enables
whole new workflows in that in
subversion and especially in CVS and
other to some extent in all the
centralized version control system a
branch is a fairly heavy weight thing
creating a new branch in subversion it's
not something you do lightly in get as I
told you here this here this branch in
your dot git directory if you go in and
look at it it's one file that is 41
bytes in length so the concept of this
branch is basically you have a file with
a name the name is v1 - mate and the
contents of the file is 40 characters
for the show on some and a line break
that's the file that identifies your
branch
and when a branch is such a lightweight
concept it's much easier to create lots
of them you throw away those who don't
want tags the same story
so creating branches all over the place
well like the the version control system
is no longer the limiting factor on how
many branches you want it's basically
how many you can keep keep track of so
yeah whenever I work with get locally I
I start like I have an ID like okay
maybe I Phi if I do this to this class
it'll look nicer in the end but I'm not
quite sure now I'm gonna do an
experiment I'll start a new branch
locally just do a few commits see how
that experiment works I'd maybe it's
really really good and I merge it into
my main branch and push it onto the
server or maybe it doesn't work at at
all and I just throw away the branch but
creating a branch and removing it its
base it's literally creating it for the
one-bite file and removing it and the
tools do it for you and and it's yeah
it's a it happens in the blink of an eye
yeah you can push the branch to the
server if you want to so so in your
collaboration environment ideally I hope
everyone that works would get have a
nice good server where they're able to
push their own personal branches so that
you have somewhere to backup your work
without having to integrate it with
everyone else and release it basically
yes yeah so basically once you delete a
branch the commits themselves don't
actually go away there is a cleanup
later what does that look like when does
it happen is it automatic yes there is
an automatic garbage collection that is
triggered by some git commands so say if
you fetch like if you come into work
every morning and you pull from the main
repository at some point you will have
pulled down all these objects and
they're starting to sort of bloat the
dist
and pull or fetch internally will
trigger excuse me
will trigger an automatic garbage
collection and that garbage collection
will basically go through your
repository make an optimized pack file
that is basically this this magic file
with all the Delta compression and and
that pack file will not contain stuff
that is unreferenced so there will not
contain those commits that are no longer
referenced by any branch and then it
will delete all the other stuff because
the pack file has all you need and
that's when you lose those commits and
you can also trigger this garbage
collection explicitly by just running it
GZ but you don't need to it is there is
an automatic fallback yes yeah how does
a git merge when two people work on the
same things so first to do to sort of
get the the other stuff out of the way
when when you have two branches your
merging them none of the or the branches
change the changes are in different
files those files it'll just take the
changes and and sort of meld them
together there are no conflicts as long
as they're there there are different
files if there are changes to the same
file and the file is a text file and the
changes are in different parts of the
file get will be smart enough to figure
out that oh I can take this part here
because it doesn't really conflict for
this part up here so I can sort of
combine everything together and we'll be
fine so only when you have changes to
text file touching the same lines of
code does get basically throw his hands
up and say oh I don't know how to deal
with this and at that point it'll spit
out a file with conflict markers in it
so you'll have this in your text file
you'll have one line of these Chevron's
basically saying that a followed by the
lines from one of those branches and
then you'll have a line of equal signs
and then you'll have the change from the
other branch and then the line of
cheiron's going the other way and it
will basically tell you oh there are
conflicts here you need to
at this and resolve these conflicts
basically create a version of the file
where you have manually combined the
changes into a way that makes sense
remove the conflict markers and then
when you're satisfied with with what you
had and you can build and test that in
your working directory then you can get
add that file to tell you that I've
resolved these conflicts now and when
you do the get commit it'll make the
merge commit with your changes in it so
that's for text files if you're merging
binary files things get more complicated
this is why we like version controlling
text files and having source in our
version control systems and not binaries
there are solutions but there to our
wants to get into now there's question
there is it possible to build test only
what you have in the staging directory
the staging directory is not actually a
real directory on your system so it's
not like you can just CD into that
directory and and build and test what
you can do is there's a command called
git stash get stash will basically take
all the changes between working and
staging and it'll stash them away
somewhere you don't really need to know
about where it is but know that ok I can
start this away and I can get it back at
some point and when you have stashed
those changes what you're left with in
your working directory wait a minute
I think it's gets - - - yeah yeah yeah
yeah so under the hood what get actually
does when you do get stashes uh sort of
creates a commit with your changes but
it's not a commit on your branches it
doesn't change your history or anything
like that but basically what you're left
with is the stuff in the staging
directory is now in your working
directory so your stage changes or left
you're working and you can now build
your working directory and test them and
that will be basically the same as as
building in testing your JS staging
yeah soget stash is a nice tool for
basically I have some changes here but
right now I just want to test or look at
what is ready for commit so I'll just
put those changes away for a little
while I'll do my other stuff and once
I'm ready I'm gonna do a git stash pop
will basically take the lost stash I
made and put that back into my working
directory and you can continue working
there was another hand somewhere so when
you sow the stash itself if we go under
the hood again and so stash is basically
this sort of magic commit that magic
commit will have as its parent where you
started from when you made this - so the
stash will know what what was the base
state from which the stash applied - so
if you check out some somewhere else and
then you try to get stash pop get will
basically try to merge those changes
into where you're currently standing and
you might get conflicts and at this
point things yeah you need to keep keep
your head straight because at this point
the changes from your stash might create
conflicts with where your checked out
and the conflict marker will show up and
tell you that oh this branch has to
change here and there's this other
branches has changed there and one of
those will be identified as stash
changes or something like that and you
now need to sort of manually resolve
that so when you wait yeah so so
basically it gets - pop will basically
become the same thing as if you had done
a merge between your state changes and
your current head and the conflicts yeah
they all show up in git status git
status we'll see oh there is this merge
going on and both so both branches had
modified this file and there'll be a
complete motor but if you're lucky and
your stash changes don't conflict with
wherever else you have checked out in
the meantime
it'll just apply the new changes and
you'll have your changes but now based
on top of your current commit and not
where you originally started from yes
yes
stick with the false if you don't know
what you're doing yeah and that's sort
of a regular good advice I think so get
get test concept of merge strategies
which is basically how to deal with
conflicts when merging well there are
two levels of Myr strategies there's
basically how to deal with the merge
proper and then how to deal with
conflicting changes so first you can I
think it'sit's get merged - s for the
overall strategy and there can do stuff
like get merged - s hours hours as in
our changes that basically tells get
that I want to I want to merge this
other branch into my branch but I want
the result to be identical to what I'm
currently asked so I want to create a
merge but I want to discard all the
changes from the other branch it's it's
it's useful in some cases but you don't
often if do it but then you have like
you can do the other thing as well say
that I'm somewhere else so or I'm at
some commit but I'm not too fond of
what's happening here I have this other
branch that someone else made I just
want to take their changes no matter
what and and basically do you emerge but
the end result should be identical to
what they had and so then you can do I
think there's a git merge - yes there's
that basically does that there are I'm
not sure if there are any other merge
strategies that you would actually use
in real life but that's the sort of top
level okay how do we approach the
merchants of all I want all those
changes or all these changes and then
you have something called git merge - X
and then some other strategy and that's
more like how do you get actually deal
with conflicts in the same files and
that's I think you get into those when
you start say merging binary files so
like if you have one image here and
there is another image and there are
differences like maybe you have some
external program that can handle merging
differences between images
and I don't remember that of my head but
it might be the get murder - exception
that he used to sort of invoke that
magic or yeah I think you can do a
similar hours and there's things saying
that if you have if you are conflicting
changes in this file then always take my
end of those changes because I don't
trust whatever came from the other
branch or something like that but yeah
there are as I said previously there are
tons of options and yeah get get will
let you do pretty much anything but the
manual page suffers from it because
there are so many options yeah yeah so
as I said yeah you have the reset
command for resetting when when
resetting your branches of resetting
your your state to something else so you
can just experiment and see what happens
and worst case you have the ref luck so
if like ah this really really didn't
work out just get me back to where I was
five minutes ago then look up the ref
log and it will tell you where he were
five minutes ago how is it working with
really really big repositories so the
the natural consequence of what I've
told you today everything is stored
locally so you'll need space for the
entire project not once but twice
well I'll get into the first since
everything is available locally on your
disk and binary files first of all they
compress badly and sort of related to
that when you make a change and change
in a binary file it often rewrite the
entire binary file so if you just looked
at a bitwise diff between two between an
image and the later version or that
image it will be completely different
there's not like just this portion of
the file changed
they buy binary files compress badly and
get suffers from that which is why we
really advise people not to check in
binaries at least not large binaries and
not many binaries in your git repo get
does really really well at Delta
compression and the and compression in
general and especially on things that
compress well so for example if you look
at the gate kernel history or say the
history in at my day job at Cisco or
many many other codes you'll see that ah
when I check out the kernel repo for
example I have working directory it's
this big say a gigabyte or something of
code and then you'd think that ah but
the docket directory has the entire
project history that must be so many a
times bigger because there's history all
the way back to I guess 1991 in that
dots gate directory
but gate actually compresses the source
code so well that for most pure source
code projects the size of the dot gate
directory is pretty much on the same
order magnitude as the size of one
single version checked out so typically
for a source core project if if it takes
any megabytes then you'll need to end
megabytes of disk space to actually be
able to clone and work on that repo this
is pretty much the same you get with
subversion because with the subversion
what happens if you check out one
version from the server and subversion
internally stores a copy of that version
inside the dot SVM directory so you end
up needing to n space where n is the
size of the current version but yeah for
binaries it's not doing well because of
all these design choices that I talked
about but there are tools there's
something called git LFS and I think LF
s stands for large file support or
something like that what happens then is
that if you check in by a binary file
with git LFS
enabled the binary file itself won't
actually be checked in to get the bye
file will be uploaded to some asset
server somewhere that is good at
handling binaries and then what will be
checked in to get is some unique
identifier or that references that asset
from the server and if you check out
some version and it finds these
references it'll then pull those assets
from the server and put them into a
working directory so you'll you'll have
been raised in your checkouts they will
look like regular binary you don't have
to do anything special except enable get
LFS in the first but yeah what you're on
your day-to-day work the files will just
be there and and it'll work but you'll
need to set up this infrastructure with
this as a server and handling binary
especially so there are solutions but
out of the box get doesn't do very well
with binary files that's a designer
session like we have decided this yeah
basically when when Lena's first met get
he want to make a virtual system for
source code yes
yeah so yeah the comment is basically
about when you have big project
structures little directories in in
subversion perforce other centralized
systems they can handle fairly big
structures fairly well and it's easy to
say check out just a sub portion of the
product and get get and get it's much
easier to create multiple git repos for
parts of your project but there are some
some downsides there as well because if
you start if checking out your project
is basically checking out this big
hierarchy of many different git repos
then you need to set up some
infrastructure to make sure that you get
the right version of the right repos
every time and you get mechanisms like
sub modules which are often confusing to
work with because suddenly you're
working in 12 different repos at the
same time and not just one and yeah I've
seen examples going both ways both like
companies that have split their
structure into many git repos but also
projects that I basically have monster
edit repos and it still seems to work
somehow like current work stations are
plenty fast and SSDs make up for a lot
of you can check out a lot of crap if
you have a fast disk
no and that's that's a good idea or a
good point yeah cloning cloning is
pretty much the only really expensive
operation in gifts because that's when
you actually talk to the server and you
pull down the whole project history
after that the only communication that
you have with other git repos is just
pulling and pushing changes and the
changes are just just what has changed
actually so yeah when you do a git clone
of a large repo that'll take some time
because it's actually pulling down the
whole project history but that's yeah
that's optional as well there are
options in get where you can say ah
don't bother pulling down the whole
history only pull down the latest and
commits or something but sooner or later
you'll
find that you'll want access to entire
project history and then you'll probably
want to sort of deepen that clone to
make sure you got everything anyway so
yes there are workarounds but I haven't
actually seen them use that much yeah oh
yeah yeah so so he's basically saying
that when like your build server is
typically checking out your d3 foe for
every bill it does so oh there's a new
version oh let's check out the new
version and build it and say that all
tests are green and all that stuff and
yes that one should probably not have a
full clone or certainly shouldn't clone
your repo fresh every time it does a
build that's just wasting time space yes
it can clone with a depth of one but it
can also do a remote call called git
fetch pack or something like that I
can't remember no gifts yeah I can't
remember the name of the command right
now but there's a command where you big
can basically say talk to a server and
yeah yeah just give me a tarball of this
one version I I don't want to do a whole
flow and I just want this one Russian
and and the server will give you that
and you can just build from there so
yeah that there are lots of tools and
lots of customization to be done yes
it's still saying that remoting but if
some of these yeah yeah yeah so so say
you have say you have to get repose of
the same project and next to each other
on your local disk you can tell one one
of those repose to find objects in the
other repo and basically not have to
store to duplicate copies of the objects
rectory and that helps a lot say on the
build server I would typically have some
master repo that you don't build from
it's just there to make sure all objects
are available locally and then for each
build you do you basically create a new
repo saying that our clone the latest
from the server but use this other repo
as a source of objects as well and
you'll find that the clone is much
quicker because you already have all the
objects available locally so for those
specialized scenarios where you do build
or check out a lot like a build servers
there are solutions to make it go fast
and probably much faster than what you
would get from a centralized version
control system yes
yeah yeah I've seen similar things where
I think there is a fuse file system for
Linux where you mount up the file system
and the file system reflects some
version of some git repo and then
basically only when you start accessing
the files that is does it actually get
those objects and check them out and
basically make them available so yeah
you basically have get running
underneath your filesystem layer
yeah so yeah there are tons of tools and
things to speed up and help do the
things you you need to get on yeah
that's just one of them a lot more
questions you have
looking at all well we're at 1830 that's
pretty much it yeah
[Applause]